we've got Parramatta clean lamb chops
with char grill broccoli and bulgur
wheat salad to cook the bulgur wheat
just simmer until tender
then drain to give the broccoli a
chargrilled flavor
simply cook with salt in a hot dry pan
until smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mixed together
Arisa paste with either buttermilk or
creme fraiche and add chopped mint
simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and bulgur wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves dessert ready and
fellas done now the aromatic grilled
lamb chops how much do you love lamb
holes a lot a lot on a scale of 1 to 10
Tom ok these lamb chops I'm gonna be
delicious first we're gonna marinate
them I'll start putting the spices in
yeah first one coriander coriander good
so teaspoon of coriander seeds in I
don't touch off what's that you assuming
well done cumin in one's daddy's
favorite tumeric Jimmy a teaspoon of
that in there now I don't touch of salt
and I want you to start grinding that
down why I get the ginger and the garlic
give that a nice little mix please for
daddy
that looks amazing I'll fat get the
garlic lay it flat
I'm not it almost pure is the garlic so
we get a nice paste
suddenly sorry about dirty your nails ok
I'll just smell of garlic yeah nothing
wrong with that the more you smell of
garlic no less the boys are gonna date
you sigh all right now the ginger makes
it sort of spicy from fruity now get the
ginger and do exactly same the ginger
you grated like this it turns into the
most amazing ginger puree offer you're
done how long how he put some muscle
into it
yeah nice steal that there your back of
the knife now I'm gonna drizzle some
olive oil in there okay
you bring that together as a pace for
daddy there you go go on the second no
come on
nice good girl
now that smells incredible that is a
delicious pace so I'm your tip all that
marinade on to the lamb and I want you
to rub it all in to those lamb chops
then we go get your hands are there my
girl
come on holes so look you get them in
there
then your rub all that marinade the
flavor inside these chops come on Holly
come on your jump is fine just smell
that mmm nice fresh and the earlier you
do this the better the turmeric is
starting to stain the lamb chops they're
not even cooked yet yet they smell
delicious
yeah what do you like honestly my nails
oh my nails delicious after marinating
from ten minutes to overnight but if you
can't wait to get your hands on them you
can grill the chop straightaway gasps
nice and high and grilling them to make
them slightly healthier so lamb on first
one then
we'll slide that in alongside that so
you sit more in the pan that's right
what I want to do is get those really
nice grill marks on there thick on
now when I cook them these sides one
side up flip it and then on the back see
this bit here gonna grill it on there as
well now if you could get the yogurt add
a pinch please don't
it's nice some fresh mint want you to
pick the mint please and give a little
chop and mix it in with the yogurt
smells amazing doesn't it
so dogger in chop up the min please have
a look at the color of the lamb over
beautiful put it
how nice are they they smell incredible
grilling in this way they cooked so much
quicker okay it's a lot healthier smell
is mmm beautiful just itis
yes very good Eric and Meaghan more
light bears I hope so
Siwon doing I'm standing the chops up
yeah we're not gonna dry out this way
except chopped tuna draw a bit more
that's fine and then mix it into the
other please darling mother taught my
dog how would you know when they're done
nice and pink between half to four
minutes each side medium six minutes
well done eight or nine minutes how
would you like your lamb my darling
medium rare
after a lamb cutlets at his best will be
medium-rare off of the gas okay so
lovely lovely flavor you can look at
that Wow
I'm in heaven I'll carry the lamb on the
yogurt if you get the bottle of wheat
and the broccoli that smells incredible
it really does fast and easy to make
pact with goodness and utterly delicious
with a bit of kitchen know how you have
my ultimate healthy dinner on the table
in just 30 minutes tell
thank you I just smell it from a mile oh
really oh can we start serving yes I'll
make up the color that's kind of you I
pass it here for you but after you
ignore your broccoli that's a long time
away nice and healthy she got her hands
dirty for the first time in 13 years
only it's delicious really really lovely